So as you can see your pattern is scored based on the number 10, so out of 10 is your mark.
As you can see it's split up into two parts, we have our accuracy and our presentation
on this side.
So we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy is actually scored from a 4, so from the number 4 you're actually marked
during your presentation of your pattern.
And then with that one, any mistakes that you make, if it's a minor mistake you get
a minus of 0.1, if it's a major mistake you get minus 0.3.
So I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So with a minor mistake, it's a very very small thing, so say we're doing an outer block,
if it's not your shoulder height, maybe it's a little bit lower, or maybe it's a
tiny bit higher, that's a minor mistake, so that's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be, you're supposed to do an outer block in the pattern, but you
forget and you say you're doing a rich hand striking set, so that would be a major mistake.
So with a minor mistake, let's say pattern 1 for example, there's 20 steps, it's not
uncommon to have up to maybe 14, 15 mistakes in the 20 steps.
So the reason for that one being 0.1.
It needs to be absolutely perfect to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So it's not uncommon to let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's say 15 mistakes.
So what would that be?
We'll leave that there on this side, and we'll come back and we'll just calculate the score
at the end.
So a major mistake, say you're supposed to turn to the left, but you turn to the right,
that would be a major mistake.
So.
We do want to try to avoid any of these major mistakes.
So after we've done our pattern, that's when we move on to the presentation side.
So the presentation, as you can see, it's from a score of six.
This six is actually split up into three parts.
So we have one, two, three here.
So with this one, for a score of two is your power and speed.
Your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression of energy is also scored out of
two as well.
So we'll start off with the power and speed.
So with this one, whether it's your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything
that you do, you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well.
So it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch, but it has to be both
strong and fast to get high in that category.
The next part is your rhythm.
So the rhythm, when you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern.
It's not just really fast all the way through, it's not slow all the way through, there's
a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect to it as well.
So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also scored out of two.
The last bit is your expression of energy.
So what is expression of energy?
That's basically how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern
as well.
So say you're doing your pattern really well, it's really fast and it's strong, you're really
fast, your rhythm is really great, but you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of
tell, the judges can kind of tell that you're not really confident, you're a little bit
nervous, so that's what we need to kind of improve on as well.
So I'll just come around to this side.
So with this one, for colour belts and black belts, it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So if you're a colour belt, your average, so where the judges actually mark you from,
is 1.1.
So this is your average, so say you did alright, you did average compared to everyone else,
your score for 1, 2 and 3, it'll start from a 1.1, so if you're less than average in the
judges' eyes, you might go down to, say for your power and speed, you might get a 1 or
even a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So each individual, you might get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So if you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So if you did really great, you might even get a 1.3.
In this category, you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt, generally, depending on the competition, you will be scored from
a 1.3.
So 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So say your power and speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4, say your rhythm
was only about average, it wasn't amazing.
might be just a 1.3 but let's say you didn't shout very loud so your expression of energy
your average was 1.3 it might drop to say let's say a 1.0 so with this one we'll comment down
to this side so with this one uh as i was saying it's a total of uh 10. so let's see
and for presentation we had 1.7
one two three so you had a 3.7 and say you made 15 mistakes so with this one obviously
don't be too discouraged if you do get uh pretty high your mistakes uh this is with the judges
we have three judges usually at the panel and each judge obviously it's very subjective so
from their point of view you might have made a lot of mistakes
or you may i may have made not a lot of mistakes as well so that's why we have the three judges
and we average it out as well okay so uh say we did our uh 15 mistakes very small mistakes so if
they're all uh minus 0.1 it'd be 1.5 so you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals 2.5 so this would be your
accuracy score
so with our presentation like before we're saying we've got a 3.7 here so we add these numbers at
the uh after the judges are finished scoring so you get for this pattern a 6.2 which is actually
very good so i'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number here so if you're a
color belt uh if you're a yellow uh or above and you do your patterns it's not uncommon generally
color bill uh the average is about a four to five so if you get a number between uh four and five
out of ten for your pattern that's actually uh generally considered pretty good so anything
above that uh you can consider yourself pretty good uh if you're a blackboard the average would
say because um we're talking here about the the higher presentation as an average anything from 5
to sorry five to six is actually considered uh pretty pretty good and anything over a seven
is actually considered almost world-class so if you get a seven for any of your patterns you
generally need to pat yourself on the back you did an amazing job so uh we just went through our
poomsae scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is a 6.0 accuracy is judged during your
pattern presentation is after and then we get the two scores that we add up and we get that number
so with this one obviously uh say i was i was judge number one i would give you a 6.2 there was
another another judge on the other side maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than i did and maybe
this one would be a little bit lower it might be a five point something another judge on the other
side they scored a little bit higher so we'd get the three numbers and then we'd average
that as well so i hope this uh helped you guys so make sure you enjoy your content competitions and
anytime i make sure obviously you record down your numbers as well
so it's minor errors this time we cannot pause the video because it's like you're
being a judge for yourself so you can just add whenever you see a minor error
and then major errors and then once you're done coordination and expression of energy
and then it will automatically compute at the end once we click continue okay great sounds good
so
i will just close the video here and i hope you enjoyed it if you did i hope you enjoyed it
and i'll see you guys in the next video bye
Thank you.